que los que más contaminan paguen el
costo en París un grupo de activistas se
manifestó frente a la torre Eiffel el
miércoles con la mirada puesta en la
Cumbre para un nuevo pacto financiero
mundial y en los 50 jefes de estado
participantes
firmó el acuerdo de París
esto demuestra que los líderes no
cumplen lo que dicen y nosotros estamos
aquí para decirles que les estamos
vigilando Qué sabemos lo que hacen
el objetivo del encuentro sería reformar
la relación entre los instrumentos
financieros mundiales y la lucha contra
el cambio climático la agenda de las
discusiones incluye temas como el alivio
de la deuda para los países en vías de
desarrollo la posible creación de nuevos
impuestos para el transporte marítimo
cuya recaudación iría directamente a la
financiación de un fondo especial para
compensar los efectos del cambio
climático en los países más vulnerables
un fondo que resultó de un acuerdo
conseguido en la cop 27 sin embargo el
origen del capital para su
funcionamiento no es claro de lograrse
un acuerdo sería la medida más ambiciosa
que adopta la comunidad internacional
desde la firma del tratado de París de
invito ahora a la cop a adoptar el
proyecto de titulado acuerdo de París
que figura en el documento Mira
alrededor veo que la reacción es
positiva no oigo ninguna objeción se
acepta el acuerdo de París para el clima
según el índice global de riesgo
climático myanmar Haití y filipinas son
algunos de los países más afectados por
eventos climáticos extremos hechos que
demuestran que las naciones más pobres
son las que más sufren la crisis
climática